Prior to World War II,
U.S. patients paid for most healthcare which was relatively inexpensive,
until the beginning of high tech medicine in the 1970s.
After the war, the U.S. economy experienced
explosive growth and employers were competing for workers.
Health insurance became an attractive but inexpensive employee benefit.
In the early 1960's,
the Federal Government created two major new health insurance programs,
Medicare for citizens over 65 and
Medicaid primarily for the poor and those with certain disabilities.
This graphic from the California Health Care Foundation,
shows our complex mixture of payment sources,
the contributions of which vary with the kind of care.
Until quite recently, most payments for health care services were pay for procedures,
where in simple terms,
individual providers and hospitals are paid,
on the basis of how much care they deliver.